[APPLAUSE]
JACQUELINE FULLER:
Well, welcome everyone.
So great to see
everybody here to welcome
a very special guest,
Mr. Dikembe Mutombo.
Let's have another
round of applause.
Dikembe's taking
the time to be here.
And before we get started--
I'll introduce him--
but before that,
let me just say,
there's going to be another
opportunity for those of you
think you got a little game.
We're going to be over at--
[LAUGHTER]
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO: There will be.
I'm going to be there too.
JACQUELINE FULLER: Yeah.
Justin's been trash talking.
And so that guy
right there, that's
the one you need to stuff.
So Sasha, what time is
that over at Garfield?
FEMALE SPEAKER: 2:30.
JACQUELINE FULLER: 2:30, OK.
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO: Can
you let them know
that I brought my shoes too?
JACQUELINE FULLER: Oh, yeah.
He brought his game, and
he brought his shoes.
So we hope to see
everyone there.
And we have Badge
to donate stations
to help support the work that
Dikembe is doing in Congo.
We'll talk a little bit
more about that in a minute.
But make sure that you do
that at the tables here,
and we'll have them
at Garfield, as well.
Well, let me start by just doing
an introduction of the man who
needs no introduction.
So I am Jacqueline Fuller,
and I run google.org,
which is Google's philanthropy.
And this is Dikembe Mutombo,
and he was born in--
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO: Dikembe Mutombo
Mpolondo Mukamba Jean-Jacques
Wamutombo.
I thought you were going to
introduce me with my man names.
JACQUELINE FULLER: Yeah.
Wait, Nick, that
wasn't in the briefing.
That was not in the briefing.
Can you say that one more time?
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO: Dikembe Mutombo
Mplondo Mukamba Jean-Jacques
Wamutombo.
JACQUELINE FULLER: Right?
[LAUGHTER]
Welcome Dikembe.
So a little bit of background.
He was born in Kinshasa
and arrived in the US
from the Democratic Republic
of Congo, which I'll just
refer to as Congo, in 1987,
on an academic scholarship
to Georgetown University.
So I can't believe
this is a true story,
but tell me if this is true.
So when he was in his
second year at Georgetown,
the famous coach,
John Thompson, saw you
and invited you to try out for
the university's basketball
team.
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO: Yes.
JACQUELINE FULLER: That's true?
JACQUELINE FULLER: So
he played a little ball
while he was at
Georgetown, and also found
the time to graduate with
dual degrees in linguistics
and diplomacy.
And as a linguist, he's
fluent in nine languages.
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO: Yes.
JACQUELINE FULLER: Wow.
So what are those languages?
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO: I speak
English, French, Portuguese,
a little bit of Spanish, and
all the African dialects.
JACQUELINE FULLER: Wow.
Not too bad.
I have a little bit of
high school French myself.
[LAUGHTER]
So looking at his basketball
resume, let's start there.
So he was drafted fourth
overall by the Denver Nuggets.
He was an eight
time NBA all-star.
He was a four time defensive
player of the year.
He had the second most
blocked shots in NBA history.
AUDIENCE: Woo, woo.
JACQUELINE FULLER: Including,
as he told me outside,
when I let him know
I was from Seattle--
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO:
Oh, there we go.
I apologize.
JACQUELINE FULLER: 35
blocked shots against Seattle
in like five games, huh Justin?
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO: I apologize
again if you're from Seattle.
[LAUGHTER]
I really didn't mean it.
JACQUELINE FULLER: Yeah.
I think he meant it.
And then you retired from
the Houston Rockets in 2009,
and just a few months
ago, was elected
to the NBA Hall of Fame.
So we have an NBA Hall
of Famer with us today.
And in fact, I think
we have a quick clip
to show of some of those
blocked shots, perhaps.
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO: Let's see.
I love to watch myself.
[LAUGHTER]
Is all of them against me?
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Number 55!
JACQUELINE FULLER:
Let's hope not.
-Dikembe Mutombo!
-Get out of the way!
Here comes Dikembe!
Deke!
Mutombo's in.
-Tumbo rolls in,
count it, and a foul.
-Oh!
-This could be his first shot.
It is!
-Dikembe said, no,
not in my house.
-Tumbo goes baseline
and throws it down.
--[INAUDIBLE] tried
to do a 1-on-1.
Watch as Dikembe reloads it.
He knew Dikembe was there.
-And Mutombo, with a foul.
-[INAUDIBLE].
And Dikembe erases it!
-It's an inside to bank it,
[INAUDIBLE] comes to help.
Dikembe rejects it!
-Second all time shot
blocker in NBA history.
-Nice play, Dikembe.
Hello!
-To Rogers again,
great position.
Oh!
Dikembe flies in
and puts it down.
-One of the great upsets
in NBA playoff history.
-Dikembe Mutombo, one of
the great human beings
of the National
Basketball Association.
A guy you got to love.
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
JACQUELINE FULLER: So
Dikembe and I met recently.
We were on a panel
together, but I was just
reminding him outside that
actually, funny story.
When I first met Dikembe,
it was several years ago,
and I was at a Clinton
Global Initiative gathering.
And there is a special
meaning for people
who cared about the Congo
and were doing work there.
And we were in this really
small, hot, stuffed hotel room.
We were all crammed in there
and talking about the Congo.
And he spoke so
eloquently about the work
that he was doing there.
I was so impressed,
and I'm on the board
of a group that works in Congo.
And then about a year later,
I mentioned him to somebody,
or someone mentioned
his name to me.
And I said, right.
I know Dikembe.
I've actually spoken with
him, the philanthropist?
And they looked at me like, and
he plays a little basketball.
So I think from that
highlight reel, many of you
are aware of what he's done
in the world of basketball.
But you may not be as aware
that he is one of the leading
global philanthropists,
and really, someone who has
set the bar for elite
athletes, in terms
of what it means to give back.
So let me just share a little
bit about what he's done there.
So he has visited, for example,
Somali refugee camps with CARE,
an NGO run by Dr. Helene Gayle,
a mutual friend actually,
of both of ours.
He's worked with the
UN, including the UNDP.
He's on the advisory
board of the National
Institutes of Health.
He's been a tireless champion
for a range of organizations,
including Opportunity
International,
Special Olympics, UNICEF.
And in fact, a few years
back, the NBA commissioner,
David Stern, actually created
a new position for Dikembe
as the NBA global ambassador.
And so in this role, he
travels throughout the world,
and helping to
grow, and celebrate
the game of basketball
through several events,
including Basketball
Without Borders.
But he has not only
been a champion
of other organizations, and is
not only the global ambassador
for the NBA, but he also
established his own foundation,
which he has given
very generously
from his own resources.
And his foundation,
for more than 20 years,
has improved health,
education, and quality of life
for the people in the Congo.
And in particular,
there's a hospital there
that you established.
And its named for
your mother-- Biamba?
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO: Biamba Marie.
JACQUELINE FULLER: Yeah,
Biambo Marie Mutombo Hospital
in the Congo.
So it's a 170 bed facility.
It cost about $29
million to build.
And when it was built, it
was the first new hospital
built there in 40 years.
AUDIENCE: Wow.
JACQUELINE FULLER:
And his hospital
was treated more
than 100,000 people
since it was established.
So why don't we roll
our second video
and get a little
more background.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-Join us and help us
realize our dream,
improving health, education,
and quality of life.
[END PLAYBACK]
JACQUELINE FULLER:
So we've established
that Dikembe is a world class
athlete, NBA Hall of Famer.
He is a world class
philanthropist.
But there's also one
other role potentially
that you might play that
people may not be aware of.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-If anything ever
happens to the guy that
does the voice of
Cookie Monster,
I can sleep at night,
knowing we have
Dikembe Mutombo as a back up.
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO: I
didn't know that.
That was funny.
JACQUELINE FULLER: I
sleep better at night
knowing that now as well, too.
So let's jump in
Dikembe, and just talk
a little bit about the
work that you're doing.
So giving back is clearly a very
important part of your life.
I heard in an interview
recently that you've
brought your kids to the
hospital and worked there.
So what first inspired
you to do this?
Because not all professional
athletes use their resources
and use their spotlight
to do this kind of thing.
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO: To
me, it was something
I've seen from childhood.
I think I just got sick
and tired to see people
dying at a young age in Africa.
So growing up in that
type of environment,
where you see people
dying all the time,
so definitely becoming
a natural thing,
that it just happened everyday.
So when I got a chance to be
in the shoes that I have on,
I saw that I can go
and make a difference.
JACQUELINE FULLER: Yeah.
And you brought your kids there,
and made a family endeavor?
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO: Yes.
I am trying to pass the torch
to my beautiful three children.
I have my daughter
and my two boys.
My wife and I, we are
making sure that one day,
when we are not here, that
our children can keep on
with this great legacy
that we have set on
and that was passed
on to our parents.
JACQUELINE FULLER: Yeah.
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO: So I
think we're setting up
a good example for them.
JACQUELINE FULLER: Yeah.
So as a philanthropist,
and there's so many
causes out there calling
for your attention.
How do you choose which
ones you're going to do?
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO:
I think you have
to look at a course
that touches your heart.
You cannot just wake up in
the morning and say, OK.
I'm going to get my
money here, there.
But it's always good to
give the money on something
you believe in, on something
that you're making sure
that it is making a
difference, is having
an impact on our
society, and that
are becoming very important.
I always tell all of my friends,
don't just give the money
and run away.
Give the money, but also want
to know where's your money's
going.
That's very important.
I think for me, I knew where
I was giving my $25 million,
where it was going, and what
was going to happen to it,
how much difference my money
was going to make in society.
JACQUELINE FULLER: When
we were on the panel
together in Florida,
someone asked a question
about how can I know an
effective organization
to give to?
And you said, give to mine.
You essentially said,
make sure when you give,
that you're supporting
something where
people are visiting regularly.
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO: Yes.
JACQUELINE FULLER: They're
following the metrics,
and that you have
evidence and proof
of changed lives for money.
And you get that
through your work?
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO: Yes.
And I've been challenging
more so my donors, especially
those who believe in my vision.
It's good for you to give
me money all the time.
I say, thank you so much.
But if there's a
possibility in your life
to spend that you can take
even one day of your life
and take a trip with me
where I'm doing my work,
that would be so meaningful
to me and to our organization
than anything else, that you
believe in what you're doing
than instead of just
giving us the money.
And that's good.
JACQUELINE FULLER: Perfect.
Well, maybe we
have some Googlers
who are interested in learning
more about your hospital
and eventually, going to visit.
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO: Maybe put the
drone on top of my hospital,
so I can see everyday
what's going on.
JACQUELINE FULLER:
Oh, we don't-- Justin,
we're not doing that, right?
[LAUGHTER]
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO: Justin
says we can do it.
JACQUELINE FULLER: Yeah.
So one of the causes that I
know is really near and dear
to you also is the
Special Olympics.
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO: Yes.
JACQUELINE FULLER: And Google
is working with Dikembe on this,
because he's going to
bring Congolese athletes,
Special Olympians over to
the World Games this summer.
And we're going to have more
than 300 Googlers volunteering.
Disability is a big focus
for google.org this year.
So what would you let people
know about Special Olympics,
and why it's something
you've chosen to invest in.
Do you have any favorite
stories from your interactions?
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO: First,
I'm glad you brought it up.
I think the Special
Olympics is one
of the great and
wonderful organizations
for any one of you that
can take part of it.
I just love the organization.
I love those wonderful athletes.
I don't call them just children,
because we do have some of them
are a little bit older.
I love their courage.
I love their spirit.
I love their parents
and people who
are very supportive for those
accolades from the day they
were born, from childbirth.
And to be there, I
think that will bring me
more joy, to just
go there interact
with those young athletes.
It's great.
And for some of you
guys who will take time
to join us in Los Angeles
in July, you will feel it.
Myself, I'm traveling to more
than seven countries in July.
And wherever I'm
going to be, I'm
going to have to
come back in the US
to take part in the
Special Olympics.
And I'm glad to hear that the
Googlers are going to be there,
and going to take place into
this wonderful game that
will bring more of 12,000
athletes from around the world.
And you will have so much fun.
You will appreciate
your time you took out
of your busy schedule to
volunteer to the game.
And you'll see.
Just come see.
JACQUELINE FULLER: So let's
talk a little bit more
about your hospital
and the work there.
So was there a moment as you
were even thinking about,
even to get more specific,
in my home country,
I'm going to do work
here-- where you were like,
it's going to be health care.
It's going to be this hospital.
And the way that you've
set it up is also unique.
You and I were talking
about that in Florida
that you've figured
out that there
are ways to get some revenue
streams, because you can get
people who need the care to
stop flying out of the country
to do so?
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO: Yes.
The whole idea was just
getting the hospital created.
The thing that hit me the
most was my mother's death,
when my mother
passed away, which
was a sudden death at her home.
And I realized that there
was something very important
that I could do in this
country and make a difference
for generations to come.
And I went and established
this wonderful organization,
and we went and
built a hospital,
which did cost a lot of money.
But as the hospital opened in
2007, we all did celebrate.
We were full of joy.
We were very happy.
But we were losing
money at the beginning.
JACQUELINE FULLER: Mhm.
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO: We were
losing a lot of money.
We were losing close
to $3.5 million a year.
And it was very difficult for me
to play basketball in the NBA,
and every day, I would force--
nobody didn't force me.
But spiritually, I was forced
to raise money every day
in every city that I went
to, either before the game
or after the game, I have to
come out with at least $350,000
every year, every month, so
I can send to [INAUDIBLE],
make sure the hospital
would stay open.
And I did very well
with the generosity,
with the support of so
many people in America.
And I woke up one day.
I said, no.
It has to stop.
We have to stop
bleeding like this.
We have to change the metrics.
So I talked to few people,
a few of my advisors,
including Dr. [INAUDIBLE],
and Dr. [INAUDIBLE],
and some of those people
who advise me every day.
They say, Dikembe, you're
going to burn yourself up.
You cannot go like this.
We have to figure out how
the hospital can make money.
Then we realized
that in the Congo,
most of the corporations,
telecom industry,
and the mining industry, was
losing close to $49 million
a year by shipping all the
executive and the top employees
to South Africa for treatment,
and getting a private plane
to take somebody who's having
a headache or a stomach pain.
And I said, but if I can
invest more than $18 million
in high tech equipment
in the Congo,
we can stop losing all
this money every year,
and all those people can come.
So we went, and we talked
to a couple mining companies
like Freeport in
Phoenix, Arizona,
that invests more than
$6 billion in the Congo.
And they went and helped us
get more high tech equipment.
And today, all of
those companies
are not shipping all their
employees to South Africa
anymore.
And they come to us,
and they pay $20 a month
for each one of the employees.
Whenever they get sick, or
whenever they need surgery,
they just get money
from the pool.
And now, we have enough
money to run the hospital,
to buy the medicine to
keep the hospital running.
It's been a dream come true.
JACQUELINE FULLER: Yeah.
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO:
I can smile today.
I'll tell you guys, I was not
smiling the first three years.
It was tough.
But now, I can laugh, and
enjoy myself, and travel a lot.
JACQUELINE FULLER: And in terms
of the challenges that you've
seen, you've talked
about how you came up
with a business solution.
And as someone who's in the
giving business at google.org,
I can say, we love when
non-profits come up
with ways that they can cross
subsidize or have revenue
streams, because it makes
the operation so much more
sustainable.
But would you say that there's
other, key lessons that you've
learned as a philanthropist
that maybe the Google employees
in this room might want
to keep in mind as they're
doing their giving?
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO: Yes.
I think the great lesson that I
learned, I wish as I get older,
maybe I can continue
to teach unto
those who want to get themselves
in the philanthropic world.
That's do not go and
start an organization
that you don't know how long
you're going to keep it going.
First, it's not just your money.
It's the time.
Make sure the
responsibility that you
have in your life,
wife, or your husband,
and your children have
been taken care of,
and make sure that are
you in your workplace.
Because you got to
keep working in life.
You can't just stop
working and then
devote yourself for the rest
of your life to philanthropy.
You will do it, but you have
to have revenue that will
keep the organization going.
I sit on so many boards.
We raise money on a daily basis.
Even the Special Olympics, we
have to keep the event going,
or we have to take care
of those young people.
So you have to find a way how
the money will keep going.
And our hospital
is surviving today,
because of all the
metrics, and all the things
that we observe to learn
and mistakes that we made.
We made a lot of mistakes.
Today, we are happy
that we are partners
with so many organizations,
including Google,
that [INAUDIBLE] to support us
in all the social innovation
we're doing, not
just by bringing
all the Special Olympic kids
from the Congo to Los Angeles.
So Google, the company
you work for, they're
supporting all of those doctors
from SEE international who
are coming to operate to
more than 250-some people who
are losing their sight in the
Congo, that maybe tomorrow,
they're not going
to be able to see.
So there's a lot of
great organizations
in Los Angeles who are
playing with their team,
with the equipment, everything,
Google.org is supporting
the organization so they
can come and operate
in the hospital for two weeks.
So we're happy with
this, all those marriages
that we are having
with all those
good people who
believe in our vision,
because you will not
do it by yourself.
That was my mistake.
At the beginning, when I
started building the hospital.
I was like, my name
is Dikembe Mutombo.
I'm a millionaire, so I'm
just going to cut a check
and build a hospital.
That's it.
And the reason I
got to that point,
because I got sick and tired
asking ball players for money.
And I went to so
many of my friends.
As I will trying to approach
them to give me money,
everybody was like--
JACQUELINE FULLER: They
started to see you coming--
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO: And as soon as
they see me, as tall as I am,
they just go to a
different direction.
Deke, I'm not giving
him any money.
So it took them almost about
20 years before some of them
decided even to give me $5,000.
But that's a different story,
another day, we can talk about.
JACQUELINE FULLER: We're going
to tell that story [INAUDIBLE].
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO:
But I'm very happy.
For me, any one of
you, anything you
want to do, even
in your community,
make sure that you put a great
team, that whatever you create,
that you will work
with other partners.
Don't try to do nothing
that you believe you're
going to do it by yourself.
I have so many
organizations supporting me,
and that's the reason why the
hospital is running the way.
It's tough to run the hospital
with 420 doctors and nurses,
and living in America,
not being there,
hoping that one day
when you come back,
all of the equipment's
going to be there.
It's very tough.
JACQUELINE FULLER: Good lessons.
So let's shift gears a little
bit and talk about your role
with sports diplomacy.
So you've just gotten
back from a visit to Cuba
in your role as the
NBA's global ambassador.
So tell us about that.
What was Cuba like?
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO: It's beautiful.
I'll tell you what.
I think it's maybe one of my
most beautiful experiences
in the last decade.
I've had so many
great experiences
before meeting Nelson
Mandela and all of that,
when he came out
from the prison.
But going to Cuba, who would
have ever thought that NBA,
and we, as a basketball
player, we could go to Cuba
and host a basketball
clinic, and help
those future generations
of young Cubans
to have a bright future?
JACQUELINE FULLER: Right.
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO:
This is a country
that is located almost 27
minutes away from the United
States of America's shore.
And it's just hopeful.
For us, we, as
Americans, to just
let other human beings
dye and suffer because
of our political beliefs.
And I'm glad that our
commissioner and our owners
made that particular
decision that
said that we are going to Cuba
as part of the cultural change
and building a bridge between
the Cubans and the Americans.
And it was nothing to
do with the government.
It was all about human beings,
how can we, as humans, connect
to each other with that.
And we had a great time.
We went there for seven days.
We did a lot of clinic.
We refurbished more than
six basketball courts.
We saw so many kids.
To see kids in a
national team who
come to practice every day
with no basketball shoes
that costs only $20--
JACQUELINE FULLER: Wow.
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO:
It was very sad.
We brought two
containers of shoes,
and we gave it to every kid.
You can see the
smiles on their face.
You see kids dribbling the ball.
Instead of looking at the ball,
he's just looking at his feet.
Oh my god, I've got
basketball shoes on.
And that's what you want to see.
You want to see that
joy, and that happiness.
We didn't meet with the
government officials.
They kind of left us alone.
But it's something
that anyone of you
should go and take
that experience.
Cuba is not far.
It's about six flights.
They went out from
the US to Cuba.
So feel free, whenever
you have time, maybe
a weekend, just go to Cuba.
JACQUELINE FULLER: Maybe
bring some basketball shoes.
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO:
No, I'm serious.
You can travel to Cuba
now with no restrictions,
for some of you that don't know.
Our embassy's opening.
Maybe eight weeks
from now, we're
going to have the embassy open.
I believe John Kerry, if
he didn't break his legs,
he was going to go
there very soon.
JACQUELINE FULLER: That was
biking, not basketball though,
right?
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO: That
was not basketball.
JACQUELINE FULLER:
No, that was biking.
So let me go back to something
you said a little bit earlier,
which is that it took a
while for you to even talk
to some of your friends
in the NBA about giving.
And there's this debate
about whether athletes
are role models or
should be role models.
I think you probably have
a perspective on that.
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO: Yes.
I believe that we,
as athletes, should
be a role model in society.
There's a lot of things
that we are responsible for.
We are the icon for the
next generation to come,
and that we have maybe
a billion people who
follow us on a weekly basis.
JACQUELINE FULLER: Yeah.
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO: Especially
we, as basketball players.
I think for the fact
that we wear a uniform.
We don't wear
anything in our hair
to cover us like
football players.
But people know us by our faces.
I think we should
be a role model.
There's a lot of things
that we can stand on,
that we can do and make a
difference in our society.
And I reject those
who come out publicly.
I'm not against Charles
Barkley, and I love him so much.
He's a great guy.
But I reject the idea that the
people who come publicly on TV
say that I cannot
be a role model,
or nobody is more about me,
because if it's all about you,
how did you get there?
JACQUELINE FULLER: Right.
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO: How did you get
to be a great NBA player if you
didn't get support from
your coaches, your teammate,
your friends, and your high
school teacher, your principle,
or your mom and dad.
You did have so many
people who did believe
in you, who did believe
in your vision, who said,
I will put my trust in this kid.
I'm going to put my
effort in this child,
and I'm going to try to help
him to get to the [INAUDIBLE]
to go, because they want
to make you an example.
So there's a responsibility
in each one of us to do.
As one of the professors put
it in a summit in an AIDS
conference in South Africa.
He said that when there's
a problem affecting
one part of the society.
It should be a responsibility
of a human being living
on this planet.
Somehow, every human being
living on this planet,
somehow, we have a role to do.
We have a duty to fulfill
for other human beings.
It doesn't matter which
part of the world,
which part of society that
you live in or you work in.
There's always a place for you
to contribute to be an example.
So these are the great
examples that I'm
giving to each one of you.
Don't say that
because I work here
in this beautiful,
magnificent campus,
I don't have any role
outside of this campus.
You do.
You're a role model too,
not just Dikembe Mutombo.
[LAUGHTER]
JACQUELINE FULLER: Uh-huh.
So are there any
players or people
that you would call out as
people who are doing it well?
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO: Yes.
The best of them,
I will say today,
who's really following
almost 99.9% in my footsteps,
I would say, Yao Ming.
JACQUELINE FULLER: Oh.
Yeah, from China.
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO: To see
how much in resources
that the young man has devoted
himself to more than 1.2
billion people in China.
He's building schools.
He's building a bunch
of sports academies.
He's building recreation centers
for after school programs.
I thought I was doing enough.
JACQUELINE FULLER: Is
he raising the stakes?
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO: As
being tall as I am.
But seeing other guys
who's taller than me,
almost at 7'7",
that I can look up.
JACQUELINE FULLER: Wow.
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO: And I say, no.
That's my role model.
JACQUELINE FULLER: Wow.
Another man that Dikembe
actually has to look up to.
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO: Yes.
Oh, there's a few of them.
JACQUELINE FULLER: Yeah.
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO: I'm
not the tallest guy.
I'm a little bit tall, but
I see tall people every day.
But I'm very glad
that [INAUDIBLE] you
have Luol Deng, who's
playing for the Miami Heat.
He's doing so much
in Southern Sudan.
You have Alonzo Mourning.
He's done so much in Miami.
You have LeBron James.
He's becoming very devoted
for the city of Akron,
also, the city of Cleveland.
We have so many, old and young.
You have all the kids
who are coming out.
You have Kevin Garnett,
and Serge Ibaka,
and all those young kids who are
coming for the new generation
are trying to keep
up with my footsteps.
And we're so happy that
so many of our players
today are stepping up.
They came to understand
that this game is good.
We make money.
But we have to make a difference
in our society, because I would
not be sitting in this
chair that you put me in,
not just because of
the game of basketball.
There's other things
that you appreciate
about me and my
personality, and that's
the reason why you guys brought
me in this beautiful campus.
And I think we want our
place to be that model.
Just do what you can do, because
you cannot be here forever.
JACQUELINE FULLER: So NBA
finals start tomorrow night.
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO: I'm going.
JACQUELINE FULLER: So I was
going to ask, who's your pick?
And you have to be gentle.
And remember, we've got
a lot of Warriors fans
perhaps in this room.
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO: You know what?
I apologize that I cannot
predict who's going to win Not
just because I'm a
basketball player,
but I work for the
commissioner office.
[LAUGHTER]
JACQUELINE FULLER:
As ambassador, one
does not pick teams.
We're going to go with
the Warriors on that.
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO: So I have
a right to remain silent.
And I'm going to take my fifth.
But I wish you guys good luck.
It's the best for my job.
It makes me look good, and
it'll be good if your city wins,
your team wins.
We're all going to be here to
celebrate, but I'm just happy.
It's the best for the game.
All these ideas are
good for the game.
JACQUELINE FULLER: All right.
So what does it feel like
to block Michael Jordan?
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO: I've
have a great respect
in the game of Michael Jordan.
And I have a great respect for
Michael, himself, as a player,
as a person.
But he was one of those
guys that I always said,
this guy's not going to get me.
JACQUELINE FULLER: Ah.
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO:
As Dikembe Mutombo.
JACQUELINE FULLER: A
little bit competitive?
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO: Yes.
I think Michael's one
of those guys that
made me to be Dikembe Mutombo.
I just challenged him every day.
And it took him about
7.5 years to get one.
JACQUELINE FULLER: Wow.
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO: As many years
as he played in the league,
he only got one.
JACQUELINE FULLER: Wow.
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO: And
I always told him
that he got me
because I was late.
He really didn't get me.
He really didn't
climb over my Mutombo.
JACQUELINE FULLER: OK.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO:
You can ask him--
JACQUELINE FULLER: I'll ask him.
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO: --friend.
But see, I'm a
super Sonic friend,
they know how they try
to climb over Mutombo.
JACQUELINE FULLER: So we're not
going to the Sonics, are we?
We are just not going
to go the Sonics.
I think we have a live question.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
your vision for the Congo.
And obviously, the hospital
is a huge part of that.
But I'd love to hear
just more of what
is your vision for the Congo.
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO: My vision is
I hope that Congo will become
a country where people are
free to elect their leader,
where everything
can be transparent,
and where health care
and the mortality rate
can go a little bit up.
Right now, I still have my
brothers and sisters, uncles,
cousins still living there.
My mother-in-law's
still living there.
So the mortality rate's still
42 for men and 43 for women.
JACQUELINE FULLER: I'd be gone.
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO: I'm
working very hard
to see that mortality
rate maybe go to 50, 55.
And I'm just putting
myself as an example.
I'm not going to be just
the only one doing it.
There's a lot of organizations
working in the Congo.
We need to help
from the outside,
not just for the
Congolese themselves.
I think it will take the world
community to come together
to figure out where's the best
way for Congo to move forward,
because Congo's just a country
so rich with natural resources.
And everyone is digging in.
It's not just the
Chinese who are there,
but you also have the
Canadians, the Americans.
So hopefully, all those
countries who feel like they
can benefit from the
Congolese natural resources.
They can also invest
in the way human beings
for Congolese people that
something is missing.
The Canadian company,
the American company,
the Chinese company, and
few European companies,
I think they benefit
for themselves.
They're not putting
anything back
so Congo can be a better
society and a better country.
We will see how it goes
in the next five years.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
This is a question
from a Googler named Javier.
And Javier says, in ESPN's
documentary, Son of the Congo,
we see how difficult
it is for Serge Ibaka
to give back to
everyone in need.
There's only so much he can do.
How do you manage to be fair and
generous with as many of your
as possible?
JACQUELINE FULLER:
And this is Javier who
asked the question, right here.
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO:
Sorry for your Knicks.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO: They
say when you're Knicks,
you're Knicks for life.
But I still love my Knicks.
Serge is a wonderful person.
And he's a young brother to me.
I spend a lot of time with him.
My father, his dad, got a
chance to play basketball
with my brother, oldest brother.
So we know the family so well.
He's trying to do
something in the Congo.
But the challenge for
Serge Ibaka, if from both
Congos, if from the big Congo,
where his mother's from, where
he has all of his mom's family.
Then from the Congo [INAUDIBLE],
where his dad's from,
where he's got all of
the family, as well.
So as being the son of
Congo, he's trying to say,
where am I going to start?
On my dad's side, or mom's side?
Where am I going to
make a difference?
So when the two Congo's
are claiming him.
So he's trying to do his best.
And the thing is I'm trying
to advise him that he just
has to be much smarter
and pick the good cause,
where he can invest
and see a good result.
But if you can just go ahead
and start giving out money here,
there, you're not going
to see a good result.
I'm working very
closely with him.
Hopefully, we're going to
see some success very soon.
AUDIENCE: With Mobutu
Sese Seko gone, and I
assume corruption's improving.
But could you talk
about if you've
had to navigate
through corruption
through your
philanthropic efforts?
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO:
That's a good question.
I think corruption in
the African continent
is never going to
erased, period.
Those are the things that all
the international communities
need to know about.
The reason I say that even
[INAUDIBLE] very good on that.
I learn the corruption
from you guys,
from the international
community.
He said, you guys cannot come
and tell me that I'm corrupt,
when it was you guys, one,
who came in my country,
trying to get whatever we
have, and trying to pull him
on the side, at the same time.
And I think we see
corruption almost
in every part of society,
including here, in America.
But the thing is when
the corruption reaches
a different level,
and then that's
when things doesn't look good.
But the government
needs to work very hard.
The country can be corrupt,
but at the same time,
there can be other areas
where there's an advancement.
And when we were
building our hospital,
I did face a lot of challenge.
We had ministers, and
people in the government,
in the lower level who
was coming and saying,
you're not getting
these documents,
or you're not getting
the permit for land
or for the construction if
we don't see something back,
like a kick back.
I'll give you an example.
We had the groundbreaking of the
hospital on September 11, 2001.
That was the day that the two
planes went through the World
Trade Center in New York.
So the reason I always
say that my idea survived,
comes from a very
difficult time,
because it was in the
middle of the ceremony
where the US ambassador,
with all of the diplomats
who came with me on the
groundbreaking of the hospital,
before the construction start.
We have to stop the ceremony,
in the middle of the ceremony,
because all of the US diplomats
and everybody from the US
government that was with me,
you have to leave the site,
because there was
a terrorist attack.
So then I have to stop even my
construction for four years.
And I stopped the fundraising,
and the hospital was not
going to get built. And we
didn't start the construction
back until 2004.
And then the hospital was
opened three years later.
But it's a struggle.
It's a struggle that
we went through.
In 2004, I want to
see President Kabila.
And I asked, Mr.
President, I said,
I'm not starting
construction to the hospital
until I get all the
documents that I want.
He said, but Dikembe,
you made a promise
to the Congolese people you
were going to build a hospital.
It has been four
years that's went by.
There's no break.
Nothing's happening on the site.
What happened?
You have all of us
on the side there.
You make us look bad.
I said, yeah, but
there's a couple people
here in the lower level, who's
beating me up, or punching me
every day.
I need all the papers I can.
So one, we were
making sure that if we
were going to bring
more than $18 million
of medical equipment
from Germany, and the US,
and other parts of the
world, we were making sure
that those equipments, it was
in the Congo with no taxes,
because I was investing millions
of dollars to the people
and the future of the society,
why the same society would
trying to tax me for
another $10 million?
I said, I'm about to give
you guys a $20 million
medical facility, and
you guys are trying
to tax me $10 million more.
I said, let's do this.
How about me just staying in
America, enjoying my money,
and you guys stay over there,
while people are dying?
So the government
ended up deciding, no.
You're going to get
whatever you want,
and I got everything I wanted.
And I'll go to
the Congo everyday
with nobody bothering me.
JACQUELINE FULLER:
Well, I'm glad
that you're sharing
the struggle,
because I think sometimes,
we feel like when I give,
and when I want to
establish this nonprofit,
and when I want to take on
affordable housing in the Bay
Area, that should
be easy, right?
You just mean well, and
you put in your resources,
and things work out.
So I think this tenacity
that you're talking about,
and the fact that struggles are
going to come, and opposition,
and then you have to
be creative, creative
as a businessman,
creative as an operator
to overcome that, I think that
that makes the story actually
even more inspiring, to hear--
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO:
Sometimes, you've
got to be a little bit mean.
JACQUELINE FULLER: And
sometimes, a little bit mean.
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO: Yes.
When you're trying to
work, you will get people,
even from the city council,
from the government, who
will try to come push
it, because you're
making higher people who came
to me, even in Africa, who said,
you know what?
Thank you for
everything you're doing,
but you do make us
embarrassed a little bit.
You do embarrass
us, because you make
us look bad, because we feel
like we're not doing anything.
Every year, you always
bring all those people here,
doing all those surgeries.
And then after you leave,
we don't do anything.
People say, how about you?
Why are you guys
not doing anything?
So those are the challenges
you have to accept,
and you have to
try to live with.
Do not try to have somebody
push you off the cliff,
and you fall?
JACQUELINE FULLER:
How would you like
to be the person
trying to push him off?
This is the man--
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO: I've got a
lot of people trying to push me
for the rebound, and I tried--
they got a lot of broken noses.
JACQUELINE FULLER: Yeah.
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO: Look at that.
JACQUELINE FULLER: Apparently,
somebody-- it wasn't me--
but somebody said maybe 22
broken noses on the other side
of that elbow?
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO: No.
You know what?
I always get accused for
being too aggressive.
And I think I really didn't
break anybody's nose.
They ran up to my elbow.
JACQUELINE FULLER: They ran.
Some faces running into elbows.
But what you're
saying is sometimes,
even in the charitable
world, you've
got to be a little aggressive.
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO: Yes.
You have to.
Otherwise, they're going to beat
you up, and take your money,
and run away.
JACQUELINE FULLER: So you have
to practice Dikembe's style
of philanthropy.
I love that.
Do we have another question?
AUDIENCE: Hi Dikembe,
how's it going?
My name is Mattie.
I'm from Finland.
And I just wanted to
ask you a question,
because something
that we see in Europe
is that with the country's
not doing so well,
there's a big rise
in countries--
there's political
pressures of countries
not to do as much foreign
aid or take in refugees.
And I wanted to see what
your opinion on something
that you're doing as a
non-government organization
versus governmental foreign
aid, and how you see,
for example, what's happening
in Europe, at the moment.
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO: I've been a
big advocate about the issue
that we are dealing with
today about foreign aid.
I think it should not be just
the European country, something
[INAUDIBLE], has been
a student of diplomacy.
I think they have given so
much aid in the [INAUDIBLE],
they will go and get it back.
It was like a death.
They're letting an African
country borrow money.
And I think when they
were borrowing money,
that money never reached
the African people.
It was staying just
in all those leaders
who went to Europe to
negotiate from a Paris club,
European club, and all of that.
That money was staying just in
Europe in the bank accounts.
And I didn't think
we're in the right place
really to name all those leaders
who took billions of dollars
from the people.
But if any countries
around the world
can go to the continent of
Africa or South America,
and invest in a society
and make a difference
in those communities,
and leave few people
from the organizations there to
just watch what they're doing,
and they hire the community to
be responsible, or work there,
that's what we did, even though
I do run the Biamba Marie
Mutombo Hospital from the US.
But we have more than 12 people
on the ground, Congolese,
that we hire, we train.
We made them be responsible
for this $40 million facility,
and to make sure to
keep an eye on it.
They watch each other.
That's what you have to do.
And you have to make sure that
the society's responsible.
Do not just come and then open
the library, build the library,
and enable [INAUDIBLE].
Say, OK.
I already gave you a gift.
I'm not responsible if the
library closes down, or what.
That's the big failure
that we have seen.
And that's why people
are tired in Europe
right now when it comes to,
oh, we need to help Africa.
And everybody was like, oh.
It's been almost 100, 200 years.
All we've been giving, giving.
But you've been giving.
Who's been following up on that?
It's always good to make
people responsible for whatever
they get.
What they're doing with
the money you give to them,
they give you reports,
and then they show you
where the money's been spent.
And that's what I
always want in people.
I'll give you an example of my
foundation, and then Jacqueline
[INAUDIBLE].
There's only three
people who work for me.
I want a $40 million
facility in the Congo,
with only three people.
And I built the hospital
with three people-- no,
with two people.
We just hired another
person two years ago.
So for the past 20 years, I've
been running my office only
with two staff.
And we've been able
to get a good result.
And we wanted people to know
where the money's going.
So when you give
me your $10,000,
I know where your $10,000 is.
So I will show you
where your $10,000 is.
And you're going to
[INAUDIBLE] too close
in Africa, so it's easy too
for the African people to say,
I'm going there.
JACQUELINE FULLER: I think
just our last question?
One more.
AUDIENCE: Hi Dikembe.
Thanks for coming today.
Congrats on the basketball
hall of fame, first of all.
My question is I'm curious.
Who is the most
inspirational person
you've ever got a chance
to meet in your life,
and what was the best piece of
advice that they gave to you?
JACQUELINE FULLER: That's the
perfect question to end on.
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO:
That's a good question.
I always say that [INAUDIBLE]
there's people I've met.
And I think there's
nobody that's
ever come close than Madiba.
JACQUELINE FULLER: Mandela.
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO: Nelson
Mandela was a great leader,
a great father, and a great
motivator, a great president.
He set so many
examples for all of us.
And meeting with him for the
first time in '92, after he
came out from prison,
in the middle the night,
where they have to shut down
the entire street lights,
and turn the lights
off at the hotel,
because he was coming
in, because there were so
many people who were trying
to kill him back then.
It was just tough to
know, to understand
that you walk in the room.
He said, Dikembe, thank you for
bringing your delegation here
to South Africa for the
future of South Africa.
He didn't say, thank you for
coming for this nation for now.
But he said, for the
future of South Africa.
And he told us, please, keep
doing what you're doing.
Do not stop, and do not
forget South Africa.
And we made a promise
to him that we're never
going to forget South Africa.
We're going to continue
to devote our resources,
and our energy, our
money to improve
the future of the
game and the sport
in South Africa for
the young people.
And we've been doing
that for 20 years.
We've built more than
200 basketball courts.
We invest I think more than
$20-something-million dollars
now.
But his advice,
please help my people.
Do not forget,
because you are part
of the future of
this generation, part
of the future leaders.
And I think it encouraged
me that I'm the leader
today in a continent.
And I continue to set an example
for so many people to follow.
And I thank you guys and
google.org for inviting me
to this campus for me
to share my vision,
to share my work, my experience.
And maybe what I was able
to translate to you today
can be replicated as an
example for each one of you
to go out to do, also
set an example in a world
that we are living in.
And it has been my challenge
for each one of you in the room,
everywhere I go to speak,
don't leave this earth
without touching
somebody else's life.
Go out as you leave
this room today,
go and touch somebody, and be
an example for somebody else.
Thank you so much.
JACQUELINE FULLER: Thank you.
Dikembe Mutombo.
[APPLAUSE]
That was amazing.